bonjour à tous je suis c'est quoi le
packtec savez vous ce qu'est le tri
sélectif je vous explique aujourd'hui de
quoi il s'agit qu'est ce que le tri
sélectif les tri sélectif est l'action
qui consiste à séparer donc différentes
poubelles les déchets que nous
produisons chaque jour et aux quatre
coins de la planète nos crimes des
tonnes de déchets mais face à
l'environnement la dégradation dans un
sac plastique prend parfois un
millénaire nous ne pouvons pas stocker
indéfiniment tous les déchets dans les
décharges en plein air qu'il faut
recycler c'est pourquoi le tri sélectif
a été inventé à la réunion comment
fonctionne le tri sélectif la réunion
les ménages possèdent deux types de
poubelles différentes la poubelle jaune
dans laquelle nous jetons les déchets
recyclables comme le papier et le carton
et la poubelle grise où nous jetons les
déchets non recyclables comme la
vaisselle en plastique par exemple aussi
il existe à proximité des habitations
des bornes de collecte de verre de
calendrier de ramassage des déchets ont
été mises en place selon les communes
collectées par des camions spécialisés
ils sont emmenés en centre de cris pour
une transformation ou bâle pour les
déchets végétaux et encombrants ils
devront être séparé est sorti la veille
du jour de collecte déposé dans la
mesure du possible devant chez soi les
autres déchets comme les pid les
appareils électriques électroniques et
les ampoules devront être rapportés chez
les commerçants qui sont obligés de les
reprendre
toutes ont tous reçu clu le recyclage a
ses limites certains produits ne sont
pas recyclables comme les pots de
yaourts les mouchoirs en papier les
emballages salle comme les cartons à
pizza puis les barquettes en polystyrène
par exemple ou cas de doute jeter les
déchets dont les ordures ménagères c'est
à dire la poubelle grise ils seront
alors brûlé dans un incinérateur ce qui
produira de la chaleur et qui créera de
l'électricité est distribuée à edf par
exemple mais il n'ya pas d'incinérateur
à la réunion sinon les déchets seront
mises en décharge ce sont des lieux
spécifiques sécurisé pour jeter nos
ordures attention les dépôts sauvages
réalisées sans autorisation sont
interdits il provoque la prolifération
des rats et des gîtes larvaires de
moustiques qui apportent des maladies et
paul elodie rannou et que pouvons nous
créer grâce au recyclage du tri sélectif
selon la nature des déchets on pourra le
recycler prenons quelques exemples les
journaux et les magazines peuvent être
recyclés en papier les bouteilles et les
flacons plastiques ont joué mon va-tout
polaire les pertes ont et les briques
alimentaires en enveloppes mon papier
cadeau le vert ont d'autres matériaux
envers les emballages métalliques en
outils comme un fer à repasser ou au
radiateur les déchets verts au compost
pour les agriculteurs l'acier le papier
et le verre se recycle à l'infini ou
comment pouvons-nous favoriser la mise
en oeuvre du tri sélectif dans la vie
quotidienne le tri sélectif est avant
tout un acte citoyen dans le but de
réduire nos déchets par exemple préféré
faire vos courses avec un cabas qu'un
sac en plastique pour favorisons les
gros paquets aux nombreux et petits
formats nous devons aussi réutilisés en
offrant le deuxième fonction à nos
matériaux désuet par exemple un vieux
tissus peut contribuer à créer une
couverture en patchwork nous devons
également réemployés c'est à dire
réparer les objets cassés ou les léguer
à d'autres personnes c'est avec ces
gestes éco citoyens au quotidien que
nous pourrons réduire nos déchets et
favoriser le tri sélectif j'espère que
vous avez bien compris ce qu'est le tri
sélectif à bientôt pour un nouvel
épisode